Roll up, roll up, step right this way, ladies
and gentlemen!
On the other side of these canvas doors, you
are about to witness something so monstrous,
so hideous, so repulsive that it will turn
your stomachs and fill you with amazement.
The creature you'll find in this tent has
been known to elicit all manner of responses
from well-to-do folks like yourselves.
You may want to laugh at it, you may want
to strike it down, you may even want to throw
rotten fruit at it, and believe you me, we
are prepared for that.
You will find all manner of rotten tomatoes,
eggs, and other festering foods that are begging
to be pelted, for the low, low price of five
cents per handful.
If you follow me through these doors and gather
around this cage quietly, perhaps you will
see it.
Wait for your eyes to adjust to the dark and
hold your revulsion until you cannot bear
it anymore.
Only then we get to look at the papery gray
skin sagging loose over a swollen gut.
Marvel at its tree trunk legs, barely strong
enough to support its own weight, its deformed
trunk that hangs limp off the front of its
face, and its ridiculous ears that flap nervously
when it's afraid.
Don't be afraid of the tusks sticking out
from its face or its cries of pain and anguish.
Instead, hold your tongues and wait, for if
you're patient enough, and perhaps with a
slight beating, it may even play us a song
with the valves on its trunk.
Then and only then, you're permitted to pelt
the Elephant Man with whatever you see fit,
as you bask in the glory of Herman Fuller's
Circus of the Disquieting!
*
Reese Freeman didn't have much choice but
to join the circus at the age of 14.
The cast-out son of a freed slave in New Orleans,
he spent much of his early life wandering
the streets, trying not to get in any trouble.
In the late 1800s, very few places were interested
in hiring a young black man, unless, of course,
they were looking to turn him back to the
life that his father had fought so hard to
escape.
That's why when Reese was out fishing one
afternoon and saw a big red tent going up
on the outskirts of town, he couldn't help
but wander over.
Much to his surprise, a group of black men
were the ones raising the marquee.
They didn't look like slaves, either.
Reese had never heard of a circus.
The closest he'd ever come to seeing one was
a traveling entertainment cart that would
sometimes pop up around town with a dancing
bear in a cage or a glass ball and a pack
of tarot cards.
The brightly colored tents that went up one
after another were enough to draw a crowd,
even the most well-respected in New Orleans
came out for a look.
Standing ankle-deep in the river, Reese peered
over at the man who came out to address the
throng.
Dressed in a long tailcoat with a tall top
hat, the man stood on a box of fruit and waved
a cane dramatically in the air.
"Good folks of New Orleans, what you're about
to witness tonight has never before been seen
this side of the Mississippi.
Wonders and amazement galore, spectacle and
intrigue, mystery and mayhem, and just a touch
of the impossible.
I go by the name of Herman Fuller, the most
talented and notorious circus master in the
entire United States.
The dazzling array of shows that I've brought
before you is not for the faint of hearts
or the weak of constitution.
Your stomachs will be turned, and your minds
may be altered, but it promises to be a night
that you will never forget."
Reese wasn't much interested in any of what
he had just said.
This kind of two-penny show was reserved for
the folks who had the money to throw around
on needless things like smiling and having
a nice evening.
What Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the scenes,
pulling various carts, and setting up all
of the stalls.
A lot of them didn't look much older than
him.
A grin spread across his face.
*
SCP-4409 insisted on being interviewed in
the dark.
With all the lights in the interview chamber
switched off, Dr. Simon Crossley entered the
room and sat down across from the Elephant
Man.
Even in the dim light, though, he was still
able to make out part of the man's features:
the ivory tusks, the hanging nose, and the
nervously twitching ears.
The man had been picked up in St. Louis, where
local police had found him panhandling in
the streets.
While he certainly seemed harmless enough,
it was important for the Foundation to take
him in just to be sure.
Sitting in the dark interview room, Reese
Freeman was apprehensive at first about telling
his side of the story.
A life of being mocked, spat on, and chased
out of towns had left him with a real distrust
of other people.
That was probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the Foundation.
He told Dr. Crossley that he was born as normal
as could be.
That his current ghastly affliction was something
done to him quite some time ago, but as much
as it pained him to recollect, it was a tale
that he knew he’d probably have to tell.
Dr. Crossley replied that he was all ears.
It took Dr. Crossley a few seconds to realize
his faux pas.
SCP-4409 glared at him before continuing to
explain how he was made the way he was.
*
Reese Freeman had managed to land a job with
the circus surprisingly easily, despite having
no previous experience and no references to
back him up.
Herman Fuller took a shine to him.
It was menial work, and not many folks were
up to doing it, but since Reese had never
had a job before, he didn't know any better.
He started out at the bottom of the ladder,
scraping out feces, washing down old cages,
and carrying heavy crates.
The once scrawny 14-year-old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17-year-old with broad shoulders
and strong legs.
They would travel from town to town across
most of the United States, stopping off in
major cities for weeks at a time to bring
in as much money as possible before moving
on.
Reese didn't save much of that money, but
he didn't mind.
The fact that he got two meals a day and something
to do with himself was enough.
In fact, he kind of enjoyed sleeping on top
of the carts as the horses pulled them along
the dusty American roads.
The one thing that always seemed to affect
him, though, was that he was never allowed
to actually see inside the tents.
He'd see folks come and go through the canvas
doors week after week but was never allowed
so much as a peek inside himself.
The older guys were responsible for throwing
the canvas sheets over the cages, which would
remain that way as they traveled.
Not having seen much of the world at that
point, Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages.
Perhaps some kind of animal from a foreign
country, something from Africa or Asia.
They made all kinds of noise.
Reese would say that most of them sounded
like humans, but then they'd go and make strange
animal sounds that no human mouth could ever
produce.
One night, his curiosity got the better of
him.
Hanging back before the crowds got into the
tent, he sidestepped over to the entrance,
making sure that no one saw him, and took
a peek through the doorway.
It was dark inside, too dark to make out much
of what was happening.
The crowd of people was standing between him
and the cage, all jostling and leaning this
way and that, trying to make out whatever
it was that was inside.
A screeching sound filled the air, making
the whole crowd and Reese outside jump right.
Standing on his tiptoes, he tried his best
to see what was moving around in that cage.
It seemed to be moving around like a person,
lurching this way and that, but the sounds
coming from it sounded more like a bird.
And sure enough, after a moment, a huge pair
of disproportionately ugly wings stretched
out from either side of the creature, flapping
and sending a rush of air through the tent
so powerful that it blew the flap wide open
in front of him, just as Herman Fuller turned
around to see him standing there.
Reese bolted and hid behind one of the carts.
He was going to be in trouble for this, he
was sure of it.
It was one of Fuller's only rules of the circus,
and he'd just gone and broken it.
He was in the hottest water imaginable.
But as the nighttime fell and the dregs of
the spectators wandered out of the tent, Fuller
didn't seem to be in a bad mood at all.
Watching him from a distance, Reese got the
impression that he might not actually be in
as much trouble as he thought.
Fuller caught his eye and came over, cane
twirling and top hat sitting jauntily atop
his head.
Reese got off on the wrong foot, apologizing
right away for spying into the tent.
The circus master just laughed it off and
slapped him on the back.
‘Reese, my boy, don't worry about it.
I've got much bigger plans for you, much,
much bigger.’
That night, as Reese lay in bed, he had a
terrible dream about what he'd seen in the
tent that day.
"Circus of the Disquieting" was certainly
an apt title for this place.
The image of that strange shadowy bird person
in the cage haunted his nightmares until suddenly,
two pairs of strong hands gripped him and
ripped him out of his sleep.
He knew better than to fight back.
This was surely going to be his comeuppance
for breaking Fuller's rules earlier.
They dragged him into the main tent where
there was an oil lamp in the middle, illuminating
what looked like a heavy wooden operating
table.
His wrists and ankles were strapped in, and
then two men left him alone.
He had half a mind to scream, but with all
the caged-up creatures from the circus around
him, he doubted anyone would pay him much
mind.
It was almost an hour before Herman Fuller
walked into the tent.
By this point, Reese expected him to be walking
in with surgical equipment, gloves, maybe
even a saw, but the man had nothing in his
bare hands.
Herman Fuller asked him if he’d ever heard
of Joseph Merrick.
Reese didn't answer.
Of course, he'd heard of the Elephant Man.
The whole world had been talking about Joseph
Merrick for months.
A man born so hideously deformed that people
had compared him to an elephant, though the
resemblance wasn't that convincing.
This sentiment was clearly shared by Fuller,
who placed one hand on either side of Reese's
face and began to softly massage his cheeks,
explaining how disappointed he was that Merrick
didn't actually look all that much like an
elephant.
Reese's cheeks started to hurt as the man
massaged him, almost as if he was stretching
and pulling at his face, finding loose skin.
The boy asked Fuller what he was doing.
The circus master just smiled at him and explained
that it was an old technique handed down in
his family, a gift he called it.
He started touching Reese's nose, gently pulling
at it with more and more pressure.
Much to Reese's surprise, he felt his nose
elongating, growing longer and longer in the
man's hand.
He tried to twitch his face and was startled
to find that his new nose twitched along with
it.
The longer it grew, the more painful it felt,
the skin and flesh from his head being ripped
and pulled into a new shape.
At several points, Reese felt ready to pass
out from the agony, but the circus master
kept talking to him, kept him awake through
the whole ordeal as he molded the boy's face
like clay into the shape of an elephant.
Lying on the bench, panting, Reese could see
his trunk from between his two eyes.
It was a nightmare, that was all it was.
But then Fuller reached under the workbench
and lifted out a small hand drill.
One by one, he punched holes into the top
of Reese's trunk, installing little valves
like a trumpet as he went.
Standing back to admire his handiwork, he
told Reese that he would be his new favorite
attraction.
‘My boy, I have made you into a star!’
*
The tusks did not come straight away.
Over the course of several months, they slowly
and painfully emerged from his deformed jaw.
His elephantine legs also were not part of
his initial transformation but instead came
as a result of health issues he developed
while being trapped in a cage for several
decades.
Crowds of people would come and go, flocking
to see the Elephant Man.
Having spent the first part of his life constantly
hungry, Reese was now being overfed every
day.
Hands would come to his cage and force him
to eat rich, fatty foods, denying him any
possibility of exercise.
The broad shoulders and strong legs that he
had developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of fat.
His skin went gray and papery, folding and
wrinkling in on itself, either from Fuller's
magic or just from a lack of sunlight.
Whatever it was, with every passing day, Reese
Freeman steadily became more and more hideous.
SCP-4409 was stuck in the circus for much
of his life.
Eventually, Herman Fuller moved on and is
currently being hunted by the SCP Foundation.
When he did, SCP-4409 was able to bargain
for its freedom from the circus.
Wandering from city to city, never sticking
around for very long, SCP-4409 begged for
change at the side of the road.
Some people would feel sympathy, while most
would feel horror at its disfigurement.
From its years trapped in a cage, SCP-4409
has developed several health issues, including
gout, severe obesity, and metabolic syndrome.
While in Foundation custody, it is fed a special
diet to counteract these conditions.
As of yet, the Foundation has no way of reversing
what was done to Reese Freeman in the tent
in the 1800s.
As Reese poses no threat to the Foundation,
he is allowed to live with relative freedom,
or at least as much freedom as a contained
SCP can earn.
His health condition severely limits his mobility
around Site-66, a low-security residential
containment area.
Unable to walk even moderate distances, SCP-4409
heavily relies on the use of a cane and a
heavy-duty walker capable of supporting up
to 140 kilograms.
Researchers listen intently at his door, waiting
to hear if he's ever going to play a sad song
on his trumpet, but no sound ever emerges,
except for his heavy breathing and sputtering
coughs.
It appears that having spent decades locked
in a small cage, a sedentary life is all he
knows now.
With every opportunity to exercise, read books,
and take up new hobbies, SCP-4409 appears
unable to engage with anything other than
sitting and staring at the same spot on the
wall every day.
If an animal has spent its whole life living
in a zoo and finds, in its old age, that one
of the walls has fallen down, what use has
it in taking a step outside?
Now check out SCP-082 - Fernand the Cannibal
and SCP-5031 - Yet Another Murder Monster!